hey what's up my name's Samuel EADS and
on this video I'm going to explain what
happens with lease option agreement
properties at the end of the term now I
have a lot of people talking about lease
option agreements maybe they've done my
courses and they've taken on the
exception agreements but not many people
that I've spoken with have actually got
to the end of the term of the lease
option agreement and it be able to
experience that gone through the
challenges gone through the whole
process is all I have because I've been
doing these option agreements now for
over a decade is here over a decade or
is it exactly I think is about 10 years
but let me play me let me talk you
through how it works
so if you firstly if you don't know what
a lease option agreement is I would
suggest that you maybe watch this video
or stop watching it and go and watch
another video and come back to it on
what a lease option agreement is but
it's effectively where you buy a house
now and you agree to pay for it later
and you have the option to buy it later
and the idea is that you benefit from
the monthly cash flow every single month
and then at the end of the term and
literally a lease option agreement can
be like five ten-year terms at the end
of the term then you're gonna buy the
property and you're going to have it in
a really really bargain price because of
capital appreciation if it hasn't gone
up in value and you don't want to buy it
or you can't afford to buy it then you
just simply don't exercise your option
you walk away and you just keep the cash
flow that you made from the property
over the years so that's why the lease
option is however what are some of the
things you need to look for when you're
doing a lease option agreement to avoid
any problems at the end so the first one
is this you need to make sure this is so
important you to make sure that you have
a solicitor represent the seller right
at the beginning now the reason that's
important is because it's nothing to do
with the contract you could just take my
contracts and you could use it and you
could do lease option agreements and
just tweak it you use the template the
problem with doing that is that the
seller at the end of the term at the end
of say seven-year term might say you
know what I don't want to sell the
property to you after all now why would
they do that why would they change their
mind they'll change their mind when the
property doubles in value and they're
like hey why don't want to sell to you
for a hundred grand
when the property is now worth 150 or
200 grand at the time in their situation
they didn't care about the capital
appreciation they didn't care about that
they just wanted to rid but now in
hindsight they're thinking hmm they want
their cake and eat it they want zero
risk they don't want the house but then
when they see it goes up they're gonna
change their mind potentially and I've
had this happen to me if you've had a
solicitor represent the seller at the
end of the term if the seller says I've
changed my mind
they can't say that because they knew
what they were signing they had a
solicitor representing them explaining
them through it they can't tell the
court oh well
Samuel or whoever pressured me or I did
it under duress or I had no idea what I
was signing I didn't know that I had to
sell the property at the end of the term
they can't say that because they've been
represented by a solicitor now you can
have a solicitor yourself as well or you
can represent yourself but it's
imperative that you have a solicitor
represent the seller so that's point one
that's going to mean at the end of the
contract to the end of the term
they can't just walk away and believe me
I've had them trolly okay I've seen it
all but they can't if you've had
estimates that represent them and you of
course this list is also going to make
sure the contract is properly drawn up
at its airtight number two really
important at the end of the term if
you're buying the property at the end of
the term how you going to afford to pay
for the deposit you might have heard me
talk about Lease Option agreements as if
they're no money down
they kind of are no money down to begin
with you're gonna pay for the solicitors
you're gonna pay a one pound minimum
option fee so it's kind of no money down
but what about the end of the term are
you gonna have to actually when you come
to wanting to get the title deed you're
gonna have to buy it then and the answer
is you can finance it in such a way
whereby it's it's no money down or you
put money in and immediately get your
money back however you're gonna need
some form of payment to begin with to
buy it so how are you going to afford
this well you have luckily five years or
seven years or however long the option
term is to work this out if you've got
bad credit and that's where you can't
buy houses you've got
seven years to get good credit and even
if you've got really bad credit after I
think it's five years it should be clean
again so you've got a long time to get
your credit so it you've got a long time
to save up your deposit and you can
literally use the cash flow from the
property on the lease option agreement
you can use that monthly cash flow store
it and then later you can use that as
downpayment on the property now if the
property isn't cash flowing anything
give it's a bad property in a bad area
it's not cash flowing positive then
don't take it on in the first place
you've got to only take on properties
even if it's a free house or a lease
option agreement there's cash flowing at
least two hundred pounds a month minimum
and if it's a seven-year a seven-year
period believe me 200 pounds a month
actually adds up to a reasonable sized
amount so you're gonna save up that
money now here's another challenge at
the end of lease option agreement term
that's this and this is something that
not many people are aware of because
they haven't completed on lease option
agreement at the end I have and lenders
will not like the fact they won't want
to lend to you on a property that you've
had previous interest in because they'll
think it's a great of a competetive
interest and you're gonna really
struggle to get a standard buy to let
mortgage so here's what you're gonna do
you are going to buy the lease option
agreement and of course by the way folks
of course it has to be a good property
this is the strategy that I've used on
several properties that's worked really
well so at the end of the seven years or
however long it is you're going to make
sure that you don't change the carpets
you don't change the kitchen so at the
end of the seven years there's a little
bit better wear and tear and you're
going to do that deliberate is part of
your plan you're going to buy the
property after seven years you're gonna
buy it with bridging finance so you're
gonna take a bridging loan and you're
gonna buy the house you're gonna have to
use some of your own money as well which
you've saved over the seven years
hopefully from the property itself you
know buy the property cash consisting of
money that you've saved from the
property and a bridging loan
bridging loans will often give you money
for the refurb as well so you're going
to buy the property get the title deed
and then you're gonna change the carpets
change the kitchen party up a little bit
the tenants will be happy you can maybe
increase the rent a little bit too
awesome then you're going to refinance
the house you're going to refinance the
house now because the property it's been
seven years it should have gone up in
value quite a bit and now you've just
done a little reverb on the property so
you've pushed the value as high as you
can get it and then you're going to
immediately refinance on a seventy five
percent loan to value mortgage and
you're going to pull out all the money
so all that's seven years all that money
that you've saved you're gonna get back
that bridging loan you're gonna pay back
and you're gonna refinance the house and
then you're left with a genuine no money
down property investment that you can
continue renting out for the rest of
your life that you secured by using a
lease option agreement but you did it
properly so those are some of the things
you need to look for that's what happens
at the end of a lease option agreement
if you found this video helpful please
do let me know in the comments and also
let me know by smashing the like button
as well people need to hear this stuff
people need to know the nitty-gritty of
lease option agreement the risks what to
do at the end of the term so the more
you like and smash the like button the
more you share the more you comment the
more the YouTube algorithm are going to
share this video around with everybody
else that's looking at property so
please help me out by doing that also if
you're not a subscriber to mash the
subscribe button turn on the
notification bell I am gonna be running
some more advanced property investment
training specifically on lease option
agreements I'm gonna be running a
webinar I'm going to be going to real
detail of how to source and find and
secure lease option agreements if you'd
like to join me on that webinar it's
coming soon you can find details in the
description below thank you so much I'll
see you next time